hey thanks for coming in and joining
this hey thanks why are you spending
some time have a seat
we'll go through our prototype here so
we're beginning a project here that is I
guess a bit of an event management app
think about it
like to news events that kind of thing
I'm curious to get your feedback on the
general flow of the app but I'm also
curious to get your feedback on some
very specific things so for instance in
taking a look at you can see here that
we have a screen where we can create new
events but I'm kind of curious to
understand from the home screen when you
first come into the app do you see
something that stands out for you that
would draw you to go ahead and create a
new event
sure so there's a there's a big red plus
there and it's red and so I'm looking at
it and that matches a lot of other
design elements on it and on Android
that's like a material design thing that
I'm really familiar with in a whole
bunch of other places so I would if I
was that at this screen I would hit that
plus and expect to create an event I'm
not sure that I would necessarily create
an event right here where it shows the
date as the 25th or whether that would
create an event that it was a lot to
fill in the date but that's what I would
expect mmm yeah you know you bring up a
great point right sensible defaults and
then the creation screen would make a
lot of a lot of sense for us in that
case like inserting the date because
we've come from a specific event a
specific screen here that lists the date
like on this screen where it looks like
this is a day view mm-hmm yeah and so
here the the plus I would definitely
expect it to create that default yeah so
the pattern there is a floating action
button and we see that pattern actually
repeat itself a little bit through the
app here one question for you the the
floating action button tends to move
around a little bit within the UI though
would you consider them to be a jarring
part of the experience or do you feel
that you understand the the action of
the button irregardless of where it's
positioned in the screen mmm so I see it
in three places here here and here which
were basically the same you know there's
no real difference there and here at the
bottom and it's nice to get it out of
the way here I think that's sort of
where I expected based on using a bunch
of other apps mm-hmm and likewise here
presumably this screen is going to move
up and down and it will stay in this
interface the border between the header
and the actual list of events mm-hmm
that makes sense to me
yeah we're contemplating implementing
some really nice animations as you
scroll through this screen so it's
possible the fab might grow and shrink
it might disappear as you scroll up
through the list but we want to keep
context in the tab headers as we
progressed through the views because it
it's important that you maintain that
information right that you'll be able to
swap between the the week in the month
very quickly now in looking at the fab
on on this particular page on the on the
week page one of the things we've seen
in the past is that the fab can get in a
way of some of the content um do you
feel that that's a really a problem for
us here I feel like right now where it
is at the bottom right you know it's
going to cover something I mean it
doesn't cover that much mostly avatars
in this screen right now yeah also given
even how many items are being displayed
and the fact that these are is going to
have to scroll through but can see
roughly three or four at a time anyway
it seems to make sense I it could not
exist at all but that doesn't seem like
that would be better hmm
okay so given that this is an event
slash to do management app one of the
things that we really want to make sure
that users can do is actually check off
and complete those tasks do you see a
clear way to do that within these
screens mmm I don't see anything that
actually says that this is like to dues
at all like all of this looks like
calendar and event stuff to me interest
um like everything here has a time uh
looks like it all has places as well the
idea of there being like there's no
checkbox there's no indication that
these are things that could be
accomplished as as another to-do list so
I don't see that interesting and so if I
were to direct you over here to these
check boxes energies these UI elements
do you feel that that's I mean obviously
when you walk through the screens here
that was a mess right um how do you feel
that we can evolve that to make that a
little bit more prominent and make that
functionality stand out just a bit more
it's a core part of the experience that
we want here and so we need to do a
better job of showcasing that feature
not sure that the the circular check box
would be as good as a square check box I
usually when we check off things in most
most applications there's an an empty
square that gets checked as opposed to
like a gray circle that changes color
and has that in there I think it's also
a little bit deceptive how this is
displayed very much as sort of calendar
events that have locations and times
which to-do lists certainly can have
locations and times mm-hmm but the thing
to do is often the the by far the most
relevant rather than the time and so I
wouldn't normally go through my calendar
and check off the events that I actually
went to whereas me the to-do list
manager having to check be more
prominent than the time would make sense
hmm interesting so certainly it sounds
to me like you're you feel that the
affordance needs to be stronger but
there's also a question about whether or
not we're actually managing to do's
versus calendar events here yeah so
perhaps the to-do aspect of the app
needs to stand out a bit more right so
this this here you know we have the
exact same things and this very much
looks like a calendar there's no way of
checking something off and absolutely we
can check it off what does that do does
that remove it from our calendar I don't
know yeah that's it you know I think
that's a great question to ask is what
would you expect to happen when you did
check something off would you expect it
to disappear from your calendar would
you expect there to be an animation
associated with that um would you want
to see it in place yeah if I'm using
some kind of a to-do list manager I
think I do want something to happen when
I check it off and that probably means
striking it out in case it was an
accidental check I don't want it just to
disappear immediately
yeah good feedback potentially it could
move away and be left with them undo but
in this case where these are these
obviously are calendar ish things I
don't want them room for my calendar I
might want to go back and see them
absolutely I think maintaining some
historical context here is really
important to actually managing the set
of events that are happening here um let
me ask you one more question in terms of
gesture support for this screen how
would you expect in a user to interact
with this to check something
as completed would you expect to tap a
swipe with this screen I would accept
expect a tap to bring up a screen that
has more detailed information so
something like this with oh I sleep like
a detail them in so you could
so tap might bring it up to edit it
uh-huh I wouldn't expect you to check it
off unless the tap was on basically the
check which is in Wyatt might be a good
idea to have it larger this is a very
small target area yeah we really want to
make sure that we have a 40 dip tap
target you know that making sure that we
have 40 device independent pixels is a
valuable part of touch responsiveness
making sure that we have enough room for
the finger on the on the screen I'm not
totally sure what a swipe left or right
might do it's possible that you could
train users to do that but it's not
super intuitive what the objective would
actually be I'm swiping up or down and
definitely should move through the list
and we can see things that are further
down um so one of the things you also
mentioned was that there was some
consistency in the experience here one
thing though is that we're only allowing
you to manage apps from the day view
would you expect to want to be able to
manage those events from your home
screen as well or is that more of like a
heads-up display mmm in the oh you mean
that here you can check them off in here
you can that's correct
if to-do list management is really a
top-level objective then probably doing
that from the home screen is really
important I mean one of the things about
to do is it's people people just won't
use them if it takes a long time to do
things so bringing an extra tap to get
through to a day view screen to manage
it to this might might keep people from
interacting with it yeah that does seem
inefficient but again here if I tapped
on any of these items I would normally
expect to be taken to an edit rather
than able to complete also is weird here
that you can edit everything about this
potential item except whether it's been
accomplished or not so here here you
have to you have to actually be in this
screen you can see the list to check
items off if that's possible
whereas here you can edit everything
else but not that mm-hmm there isn't
even a notion of delete yet here either
right right where would you expect to
see delete would you expect to see that
with completion here in the Edit you are
I would have definitely expect it to be
in the Edit UI at some place because
when everything else fails people are
probably going to go look for it there
it also protential e is reasonable for
two for a swipe gesture to move this off
and yeah interesting
so maybe swipe one way to complete swipe
another way to delete that's that is a
method of interaction that for instance
gets used on inbox and so I think it's
pretty familiar to a lot of users yeah
that particular swipe affordance is
quite popular in in boxes as well yeah
great well I really appreciate you
coming out and giving us a little bit of
feedback on the app but you've
definitely caught some glaring issues
for us we definitely need to iterate
here a little bit more but I would
really appreciate getting more feedback
when you we have iterated and improved
based on the feedback you've given would
you be willing to give us more feedback
in the future yeah great thank you very
much